oMG he's an idiot hi how was Trump other
than a douche Melania Trump is a
disaster I have no idea how
destabilizing his presidency would be no
no he's not we'll stop it
I want to believe the path you threw out
for consideration in Andy's office if
there's no way he gets elected but I'm
afraid we can't take that risk
it's like an insurance policy in the
unlikely event you die before you're 40
I can't pull away what the f happened to
our country lease that was Peter struck
testifying on Capitol Hill today he
occasionally had a clear memory specimen
was asked to read his text out loud by
Daryl eisah but at other times it was
surprising how fuzzy his memory was like
when he was asked about softening an FBI
statement to benefit Hillary Clinton
metadata shows that you mattified the
draft statement on June 6th is this one
the phrase grossly negligent was changed
to extremely careless sir again I don't
recall specifically when it happened was
it your computer that put the change in
statement based on my subsequent review
of that metadata I believe that to be
true okay and who who has access to your
computer
anybody beside you no I do my secretary
had access to nail'd while this was
happening on Capitol Hill today
additional emails between struck and
Lisa pager release discussed that
judicial watch his own president tom
Fitton who made it happen with this FOIA
request Tom first off your take of what
we saw today well it was a bit of a
circus and it ought to be only the
beginning frankly in terms of getting
information out of Justice Department
and FBI I don't understand why the
mauler operation is still going on given
the corruption evidence in these texts
that struck admitted to we're not
talking about bias here we're talking
about corruption this is evidence of
corruption an FBI agent a senior FBI
official wanting to direct an
investigation a certain way to target a
political opponent and on top of that we
have Mr Mahler seemingly disinterested
in this corruption he kept it from the
American people for months he and the
Justice Department that he had to remove
struck because of this corruption and if
I were Congress I'd call him call him in
and ask him some questions about how
he's managing he isn't that
nation and the evidence of bias and
corruption with his knee that is still
undermining the credibility of the
entire Justice Department FBI he's using
a target Trump I understand you got some
emails and text messages today what do
they say well they give it there they
show communications between page and
struck first of all we had the sue to
get the records the Justice Department
FBI want to take up the two years to
turn them over to us so they're giving
them to us in dribs and drabs and
they're from 2015 they show the
relationship between page and struck
work White was quite close in 2015 and
he's cursing everyone out he's cursing
decisions about the FBI they're making
fun of colleagues and they show that mr.
struck was quite truthful in my view in
the way he communicated with Lisa page
about how it was analyzing what the FBI
was doing one of the big lines we heard
today was that this was all personal
look right we wouldn't be getting these
text messages and person and the emails
if they were personal by law that reason
we're seeing him is because their
government emails about government
activity right
anyone who says it's personal political
beliefs if that were the case we
wouldn't be seeing them 40,000 already
we know about you say we got more you're
still going through him real quick
he also went out of it he also went out
of his way in his personal message to
try to explain away his behavior did he
do it effectively to you no he didn't
you know look your listeners the viewers
are just going to have to decide whether
they take his word that the bias that an
impact of the investigations of the IG
didn't believe it mr. Muller didn't
believe it why should anyone else
believe it he did the facts are what
they are he tried to spin them and we
have to decide as adults what to do with
this evidence should we allow the
corrupted Muller investigation to
continue given his involvement and the
involvement of several other FBI
officials who thought like him in
directing it and creating it Tom
gratulations continued to go through all
that stuff you are relentless as this
Judicial Watch is to get to the truth
appreciate it and you're welcome thank
you